we watched willem dafoe as joker we saw
harrison ford in solo a star wars story
and now we're gonna see
john krasinski as captain america but
before we go into that we gotta thank
today's video sponsor
skillshare what there's no sponsor today
oh man it'd be so cool to get a skill
share sponsor though
all right let's just watch this
are you nuts you really have got
you need
it's crazy the start tower
building in new york wow
whoa i know you're nervous you have
plenty of reason to be
wow he really could have been him
he really could have been him during the
building
well the people who think you did are
coming here now they're not planning
you pulled me from the river yeah todd
krazinski's nose though
[Music]
ouch so let's get this straight we
barely got out of there
pretty much
that is
open a tab
from outer space i want to know why loki
let us take him
he's not leading an army from here i
don't think we should be focusing that's
so
great
damn he really could have that's crazy
yeah i was gonna say
yeah i gotta say cause because john
krasinski
i believe he did audition or was one of
the top people considered for
captain america i can't imagine anyone
else doing captain america after chris
evans so i especially couldn't wrap my
brain
around john krasinski doing captain
america there was something about
earlier that would probably just be
distracting his jockeys
you know so you could hear like wow he
really could have been him
yeah yeah he really could have pulled
him off yeah he really could have it's
fascinating and too like just a shmoop's
work again
like transposing and matching the
lighting and things like that for these
various scenes and also the motion
of the head like actually kind of
morphing the shape to get his entire
head
in there like i don't know exactly how
you put it together but it's a lot more
convincing than the prospect of john
krasinski as captain america has ever
been to me
even seeing this i do think that chris
evans has that
extra smidgen of like american square
jar
jawedness krzezinski definitely has that
you know all-american thing
and he easily could have done it yeah
well in multiverse of madness they're
talking about having a bunch of
alternate versions of
our main heroes make appearances like
get some famous actors in those roles
just to make like little cameos or
something like that
so matt damon can really be low-key yeah
it could be loki
john krasinski could be captain america
that's great on the
especially on the head replacement
because a lot of times it is they're
just
they're switching out just the face
people usually just work with the head
shape and that's when it could look
really off when their face does not
match with the head shape and you're
seeing these side by sides you didn't
just deep fake
the face you like deep deep head
one two maintained like the captain
america hair
too because like that looks like cap's
hair so like yeah this is like a yeah
it's a
it's an impressive blend job all right
guys well what did you think about this
deep fake would you want to see john
krasinski
make an appearance as captain america
alternate version in multiverse of
madness or you just want to take on the
role
of mr fantastic like how everyone else
wants it
well i wanted to i don't know i'm
sounding like a cynical about that
subscribe to shamook subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell and last but not least
pj who we call pandemic jones but you
know what i don't want to call you that
anymore buddy i think we should give a
different name for pj
so what i've been wanting to call you is
pensive jesus oh that's a good one
now if i knew what the word pensive
meant
boy could i make a riff on it but i
don't
so i'm going to assume that this means
you are a high
caliber version of christ your own
personal jesus
it's another tj better we're going with
that
for our personal jesus depeche mode
wrote it about you
[Music]
you